thank y'all for us mate um did you all
know that every single time you see
these big ocean containers container
ships out here in the in the bay and did
you know that every single time you ship
a container there's a piece of paper
that's actually flown across the ocean
to serve as title to the goods is think
about this for a moment it's madness
that there's actually because every time
you ship a container there's a new owner
on the other end of the ocean and we're
actually flying pieces of paper around
the world to serve as title still
thankfully we're starting to change some
of that at Flex port others in the
industry we're making it possible to use
the internet for what it was made for is
to do commerce across the world and
fulfilling the original purpose of the
Internet I first discovered that when I
was a when I graduated from Cal go bears
we I couldn't find a job it was 2002 I
didn't really know what a job or a
company was at that time although it was
the middle of this dot-com boom that my
interests were much more around global
trade and economics and why some
countries are poor and some countries
are rich some people are poor and some
people are rich and that there's not a
lot of jobs in that space there should
be more but there not a lot at that time
at least and so I got a job working for
my older brother actually my first job
at at school was my older brother ran
this business buying motorcycles in
China and selling them on the Internet
as well as through live car auctions in
the United States and I moved to China
spent two years working for him and
working with sort of joining the company
doing everything as an entrepreneur does
we we didn't sell that's a Honda bike my
marketing team made that we we didn't
sell Honda's we sold a chili which G Lee
bought Volvo a few years ago she leads
the chinese car dealer a chinese car
company that bought volvo at this time
this was in 2005 when I was living in
China Julie made motorcycles and they
were they were not great motorcycles I
still have some guilt on my conscience
from selling these crappy bikes without
enough spare parts except one of the
things I learned however
was that trade is just broken that it is
so hard to ship something and you have a
really hard problem if you're
entrepreneur you have very hard any
business actually as really hard
problems I call them if you could
categorize them simply as supply and
demand in supply you have to make a
great product at scale if it's a
physical good this likely means
manufacturing in a lower-cost
country more and more it means making a
differentiated product which is almost
impossible look how many smart people
are in this room and if you want to
stand out how are you gonna do that
around they'll and think about all the
people in the world to stand out it's so
hard to make a good product so that's
the supply side of the equation
demand you have to find customers you
you've got to make in more and more that
means building a following having a
brand a community all of these things so
you've got supply and demand my
fundamental belief is that if you solve
those two problems you should have a
good business and we found over and over
again even when we hadn't solved those
problems even when something wasn't
going right with our supplier we didn't
have a great brand we would still get
hung up on the part in between how do I
get these products from the supply to
the demand it was super hard
we had complicated compliance customs
like what documents do you need it's
very confusing you need to you need to
trust your freight forwarder your
customs broker these freight companies
and they're not the most trustworthy
gang let's say there have been even
since I started Flex port numerous
criminal arrests for price conspiracy or
what do you call it that price collusion
fixing prices it seems every couple of
years the industry can't help themselves
they all collude and make the fuel
surcharge the same for you see it on
your airline ticket sometime so you
couldn't really trust the people once
they have your merchandise it's in their
possession and you can't get it back so
they can then charge you whatever they
want it was a very frustrating
experience as an entrepreneur because
I'm Here I am I didn't have any money
what we would do is actually buy the
container of goods and
we did you could you can in global trade
you can basically place a down payment
you can pay 30 percent down and then
they'll just sip the stuff to you and
your the seventy percent once it's on
the boat but the boats already moving so
really you don't know the seventy
percent until it arrives so you've got
like a three or four week window to sell
as many of those things as you can get
cash and then pay your factory and so we
were very bootstrapped and lean in
entrepreneurial running these cycles
always a hair away from bankruptcy and
so then when the great forwarder would
hold your merchandise and not release it
over some document that was flown across
the country or across the ocean and the
wrong you didn't get the right people to
sign the document you need to send it
back it was a real nightmare
and I this was in 2005 and six is when I
was living in China running the supply
chain for this company and realized at
that time that it was broken
now I didn't start flex port to solve
that problem for exports designed to
solve this problem four companies make
it easier more transparent give people
data visibility control over their
supply chain I didn't start flex port
until 2013 as I only mentioned at that
in that window in between there was like
an eight year period and that's a period
I would like to talk about for a minute
because it there's I had that I had seen
the problem I had experienced the
problem firsthand it made me mad and I
didn't do anything about it and that's I
think that's a pretty common experience
and one that might be a void a bowl if
we just let ourselves to get a little
bit more pissed off sometimes that it's
not you know when something is not right
and it it's broken you should let
yourself get angry you should be like
hey this is this is shouldn't work like
this this should be easier I was a I was
guilty of what Paul Graham the founder
of Y Combinator my first investor my
friend what he calls he has a great
essay called shlep blindness it's a
great Paul Graham essay you should you
should read it if you haven't already a
shlep is a Yiddish word for an arduous
journey
and slept blindness is when a problem
seems so big and overwhelming that your
brain your conscious brain just shuts
down is like there's no possible way I
could solve this and you don't even
think about it
in the essay his example is stripe where
anyone who ever sold anything on the
internet who sold something on the
internet before so if you would see for
the Digi stripe were to use some
platform if you had run a website before
stripe you had to set up what's called
merchant processing and these were done
by banks usually like Wells Fargo was my
merchant processor you had to apply and
some three months later they would give
you permission to charge people of
credit card fees to charge people money
with a credit card you had to get
permission you had to apply please let
me sell something um and if what's
interesting about this is that every
internet entrepreneur in the world went
through that process like by definition
if you sold something on the internet
you had to go through this process so
all of us saw that process all how
painful it was and then went on about
our business and sold cookbooks or in my
case dirt bikes or whatever else you
sold on the Internet
you saw the problem it stared you in the
face this is way too hard to accept
credit cards and it's now I read today a
twenty billion dollar market cap company
so there was this idea that just stared
everyone in the face with twenty billion
dollars and we also had every single
entrepreneur on the planet saw it and
didn't seize that moment and and and
Paul's new favorite example at least in
private in an email that he sent me is
Plex port which is anyone who ever
imported anything which look around
every almost everything got imported
from another country and every single
one of these businesses and
entrepreneurs saw this experience this
it's way too hard to ship stuff and just
went about their way selling stuff
instead of saying hmm like maybe I could
be the one to fix this and I I think
that that's a very important lesson
whether you're starting a company or
working for a company that you take that
and say there's your brain is gonna shut
down when it sees a problem being too
big doesn't have to be in a company by
the way you see it every day if you live
in San Francisco what are we going to do
about homelessness or other causes other
problems that we
in society let them get you should get
pissed off about this stuff and and and
know that like if you're not gonna solve
it who is there's not someone else
that's going to come and solve our
problems in general so I I was guilty of
this as well I learned about the problem
of how hard it was to ship stuff in 2006
and I didn't start flex port until
really made it my full time job in 2013
and in between I I wasn't I didn't do
nothing I discovered that that same
document that's being flown across the
ocean is turns out it's a public record
in the United States and no one had done
a good job collecting all of these
making it searchable and accessible and
they're full of valuable data you can
see every single product that's imported
into the country who made it who sold it
where is it where's it coming from and
going to
so I between sort of 27 2007 and 2013 I
built this business where we collected
now four hundred million of those
documents digitize them and sell
subscriptions to the database now that
business has is it's a good business
actually it's a very valuable product
but it has a bit of a problem and that
the data is maybe you can identify it
for me we sell subscriptions to a
database of public records there's a
keyword in that sentence that's this
challenging which is public and that
means someday it will either be free or
someone else government will make it
actually searchable or it'll just go
away and and it's not very defensible
let's say so if you're talking about
that those core problems of supply and
demand on the supply side of that
business you're you differentiated maybe
not is it defensible and if you don't
have a defensible business you're likely
not to have a business at all in the
future so I lived with some degree of
paranoia for a number of years about I
remember when Obama launched data.gov
that I almost had a heart attack that
day before I realized that they had not
put these public records on dated iCub
yet and so I started working on what are
the other problems in this space I
really love this space or the internet
meets trade for me it seems like the
the original core purpose of the
internet the commercial internet the
dot-com portion of the internet was to
allow commerce they allow the idea of a
seamless web of Commerce that any two
people on planet earth could trade with
each other and global trade often gets a
bad name
because it's usually done by big
anonymous faceless institutions and we
all know you make kind of most stupid
decisions are made in big groups and and
and yet if you were to have one person
say a basket weaver in Guatemala selling
her baskets to someone in Iowa like who
would look at that and go this is
horrible and and so when you when you
bring humanity to the problem I think
it's much more you realize much more how
powerful trade is as a vehicle for
Entrepreneurship or opportunity we can
look at the stats in Asia over the last
thirty four years especially in Asia but
around the world we've looked at almost
a billion people out of poverty with
free-market economics yeah and allowing
people to participate in a global
economy and so I look at that and I
learned about that at Cal and afterwards
you look at that on the one hand yours
appears a force for good one of the
greatest forces for good I would say the
two greatest forces for good or trade
and in the internet and and we've got on
the one hand this incredible powerful
thing and I've witnessed firsthand how
hard it is and why couldn't we make
software to make this easier so I I came
to realize that I could spend a lot of
time though that it would be a very
meaningful way to spend time and if
there would be a great business for it
and I'll walk you through a little bit
of the story but I wanna talk a little
bit more about trade and how important
it is to humanity we we know there's
evidence of trade that goes back at
least 40,000 years older than the
evidence for art for language for more
or less all it is the thing that defines
humanity to a large degree is that we
trade where the animal kingdom does not
trade Adam Smith has a great quote about
this that no no man ever saw a dog trade
a bone with another dog that we and so
and yet here's this thing that's the
essence of humanity that's extremely
powerful that that brain
we know that no two countries I still
believe this is still true with the
McDonald's have ever gone to war with
each other
so commerce global like the ability to
connect the global ecosystem is good for
peace anytime that you have two
countries that are engaged in a dispute
with each other a conflict you can be
certain that the trading communities
those who are involved in business and
doing trade with each other will be
passionate advocates for peace between
those two countries is it's not good for
business
when you have conflict my there's a
famous paper called eyepencil it's an
academic paper from the 60s I am where a
I presume an economist showed how there
is no human who knows how to make a
pencil that it to make a pencil you have
to know first off how to make wood how
do you make wood you need to be able to
chop down trees how do you chop down
trees you need to have steel so now all
of a sudden you need metallurgy how do
you do that that's that's a very
complicated thing I couldn't begin to
tell you how to do I think I know how to
make a pencil I don't that's just for
the wood you haven't mentioned the
graphite we have to go underground and
mine it the rubber you have to know how
to grow trees create rubber maybe a
synthetic these days but how do you
there's no human there's a one human
that could make something as simple as a
pencil and so trade is how this all
comes together is that we exchange not
just the object but the ideas that go
into that object every time you engage
in trade so here's something this cord
of humanity and it's just pretty broken
I've lived it firsthand ask you ask you
any family members who have been
involved in trade trying to ship
something they will they will regale you
with stories about what a nightmare it
is so I started thinking about this when
when my last business was causing me a
degree of paranoia and wanted to
experiment I to see if in fact other
people would would if companies would
buy if I built this service would
anybody buy there's a entrepreneurs or
there's a there's an idea that
entrepreneurs are risk takers and that's
not because it shouldn't be true and I'm
not I don't see myself as a risk taker
we in fact I
I want to make sure that people before I
take any risk that someone's gonna that
it's going to work I want to have a very
high probability of success so I built
in I once it was in 2010
well before I truly founded flex board I
built a company I built a website just a
marketing site offering an online
service to help people clear customs to
help companies clear customs so allow
you to file the paperwork needed to get
a product into the country I let that
website run for a year I was still
running my other company but I built
this on the weekends and during one year
of this website operating I got 300
companies to sign up including Foxconn
which is the maker of the iPhone Cargill
big AG company and then one day Saudi
Aramco signed up for my website which is
the largest company in the world the
Saudi national oil company signed up for
my fake website it was just a marketing
site I didn't know how to ship anything
I just wanted to see if this existed
would someone buy and that was in 2010
or so and so it took me the better part
of three years to get learn how to ship
stuff how to do customs get licensed
heavily regulated industry we had to
learn a whole lot of things and and I
think this was even I don't remember
when that book the Lean Startup came out
but we're there Plex port is that the
ultimate lean startup that we have been
from the start and I think we're now the
world's largest lean startup that we are
constantly experimenting would someone
buy this if it worked if we could do
this would you buy and that's beyond the
art of sales the in sales is very
underappreciated as an art as a science
as it as the core driver of business the
ability to sell something the ability
convince someone that and and
entrepreneurial sales means that you
never get a no ever you get a yes if and
then you know it might it may end up
being no because the if is impossible
but you always get it yes if yes I would
buy from you if you could clear these
cantankerous which I couldn't do but I
at least I got a yes if from from Saudi
Aramco
and this is really underappreciated
there are currently only three
universities in the United States that
offer a major in sales it's probably 20%
of all the jobs in this country and an
important part of every job even if
you're a scientist you need to be able
to persuade people of your ideas and we
only have three universities Florida
State Baylor and Weber State in Utah are
the only three universities offer a
major in sales I guarantee you graduates
of that program going to make a lot of
money and go on to be very successful
because it is something you can study
and learn and so those of you who are
engineers here in this program don't
discount the role of sales you have to
get out there and talk to users and find
out what is it what is your problem
sales is get a bad word right we think
of like the used car dealer that's like
the image that you have as you think of
a salesperson and I it's just wrong a
sales persons job is to understand
customers problems and figure out can I
solve that problem and if you can solve
it in a way that allows you to make
money you've succeeded
there's purest problem-solving so III
don't know if I'm a great salesperson
but I value sales very much I'm flex
board has always been Sales Lead always
will be sales lead because that means
we're customer led we're customer
obsessed going out to find customers and
help them with this important problem of
shipping things and making it easier for
them so it's a massive industry freight
forwarding is what we call it the art of
shipping Freight across the world to
ship one container across the world I
mentioned that piece of paper but to
move a container across the world you're
gonna have as many as 15 companies
involved in this chain it's basically a
relay race of unstructured data being
handed off from node to node by human
information brokers people are going to
look at it and it should be called
Freight email forwarding you take you
then you say okay what do I do next and
then forward it to the next person in
the chain in a relay race and what we've
just what we've said is if what we what
we are doing is building a platform to
structure all of that data make it
reusable connect all of those companies
together to a single platform and allow
them to do business together bring
everybody together and make it seamless
from end to end in the process we make
crate cheaper to ship while giving a
better user experience and if you can be
cheaper and better in a two trillion
dollar market you can grow quite fast
and I'll show you some of our I do have
a revenue graph in here somewhere but
our mission as a company is to make
trade easy for everyone I've mentioned
already why I think this mission is
really important and the way we do this
technology so we've got a platform that
connects all the parties this is much
harder than I thought the bank lad
didn't understand how hard it was I just
when I originally started the company I
was just thinking about my own problem
it's too hard to ship stuff and I didn't
know why that was true I could tell they
weren't using tax because there were
pieces of paper being flown around but I
didn't really understand that there's
these fifteen different companies in a
chain all depending at any problem
upstream results in all these problems
downstream I've learned that once we got
started and so what our technology
platform looks like is interfaces
whether it's a a web interface mobile
apps now for truck drivers a lot of it
is api's and an older standards of inner
data interchange technologies to connect
all these companies together let them do
business the mobile app is probably one
of the more interesting aspects of our
tag where we now over four thousand
trucks that we connect the a mobile app
to allow these trucks to to us to
dispatch the trucker so we don't have to
call every time a container arrives in
the port we can just dispatch a trucker
we didn't have that when we started we
started with a nice little clean UI when
we were talking it was I hear I can a
little bit of a one-man band but I can
build an application that helps you as
it as an importer as a brand manage your
Freight and all the stuff on the back
end we were doing manually and we've
been going step by step building the
apps for the for the different parties
so tech helps a lot but tech is not
enough at least in this business because
there's a huge amount of infrastructure
required we're talking about real
infrastructure warehouses trucks planes
ocean carriers ocean you know ships
trains we ship up by all modes of
transport
and how do you connect that in some of
it we own release we now have four
warehouses and one 747 that we as flex
force logo on the side is pretty cool
and it we have but a lot of it we don't
least a lot of this is business
development it's going out and finding
the owners of those assets of that
infrastructure and understanding their
needs and treating them as a customer
and saying okay what how do you make
money you make money when your ship is
full you make money when and how do you
fill your ship having predictable
customers who will show up with the
freight that they booked and so we've
had to go out and and make those
partnerships I think this is a something
that a lot of technologists are afraid
to do it was part of why this
opportunity was still available is still
available because technologists think
that you can sit in a room and build
technology and change the world a lot of
the real world a lot of the world's
problems you can't deduce from first
principles at a whiteboard in a room
yeah actually I have to go out there and
talk to people and learn how it works
there because it's not built on logic
it's not logical that you fly a piece of
paper across the world that's just how
it is
and you won't you could get geniuses in
your room and they wouldn't be able to
solve this because you've got to go out
in in my case and drink whiskey and Hong
Kong until 4:00 a.m. until you convince
them to give you some space on their
container ship and so it's not just tech
it's also infrastructure and business
relationships that go into that and it's
also expertise clearing clearing goods
through customs is something that
technology just won't do it until we
have real AG I you're not going to be
able to classify a product by customs
code it's it is very difficult for a it
requires a lot of judgment because this
is the law and the law is built on human
judgment it's not built on algorithms
yet so it is the combination of these
three things that makes flex ports
special that you're actually like
pulling from multiple disciplines being
cross-disciplinary
is super important that you have to go
out and pull the best ideas use tech but
combine it with human expertise and
combine it with real real world
infrastructure and I like to sometimes
say that flex Porter
a bit of a decathlete in that sense that
we're not the probably the best
technology company in the world were not
the best at infrastructure and I don't
think we have the most expertise but in
the unique ways that we combine that we
can create a lot of value for customers
and what our customers trying to do
they're trying to ship Freight they're
trying to have visibility over their
products when I was a kid
set that long ago I graduated from Cal
in 2002 there was no Wi-Fi I did which
meant there was a point of having a
laptop I used to go to library to use
computers because what was the point of
a laptop if it can't connect to the
internet
I would there were no cell phones like
this is weird it's not that long ago I
don't feel that old and and yet the
world has changed dramatically since
then and one of the big changes that
customers are now in charge consumers
are in charge if you're when when there
was only three television channels when
I was a kid
brands could get away with three week
the Sears catalog mail order it took
three weeks to get your stuff maybe six
if you offer that today nobody will buy
your products it's to day and more and
more its two-hour delivery is the
expectation when there was only three
channels there were only two brands
energizer and Duracell and you had to
choose you want the Energizer Bunny or
the copper top there weren't infinite
proliferation of SKUs Amazon now you've
got 80 million SKUs I think on Amazon
you got the customer has so many choices
and real-time on-demand what does that
mean for a supply chains how is that
relevant to this time well in the old
world if you have three-week delivery
time you can get away with one warehouse
in the middle of the country and serve
the entire population from that one site
in the new world that we're heading into
and that we are now living right in the
midst of you've got if you want to our
delivery what is that you need little
small caches of inventory everywhere
you're gonna see brands there's probably
an Amazon Fulfillment Center within 20
minutes of here how else could they do
to our delivery because they're out
there not like leaving the warehouse for
either running milk runs so if you're
gonna have small tiny pockets of
inventory everywhere you can manage that
the old way with emails and pieces of
paper you your you'll go crazy
you're just not physically possible
so that's what we're positioning
ourselves for is like the world where
you have small little bits of inventory
everywhere and you have a dashboard to
control it all and you have AI deciding
when to buy things where to buy them
where to position them to be ready for
the future
so like if I if I was to flip this light
switch this I'm taking a risk here I
don't know if it'll come back on did I
get it uh try you can imagine how do I
turned off the lights there we go when I
did that in real time I just activated a
power plant it just got a little bit
hotter in real time on demand your act
there's an incredible most interesting
thing I learned last year I did I don't
know much about physics but you flip the
light switch you are controlling a
massive machine you personally it's
responding to your demand and that's the
way that's not the way it works in
commerce and commerce you place an order
on a website and there's a bunch of
people making phone calls and duct tape
and wires sending shuffling paper and
three hours later you get some
electricity and think about how much
poorer we would all be in that world how
much less power you would use and that's
the way our commercial infrastructure
works right now is you place an order on
a website it does that the factory does
not receive any signal about that order
like ever
there's many months later somebody with
an Excel spreadsheet is deciding how
much good how many goods to order the
next quarter and so what we're trying to
do is say okay let's build this network
we we on board all the world's brands
and every time we get a brand right now
we got four factories on average so we
this is where the ten thousand number
comes from we've got about ten thousand
factories in China on the network and
when when a customer gives an order it's
sending a signal back to that factory to
queue up production for the next for the
next cut and decide when to when to ship
it how to ship it and where to position
it to be ready for future demand and
start being predictive about this is a
great application for machine
intelligence by the way you should not
be humans should not be making these
decisions it's too hard too many too
many variables
and so it is that combination when and
what's very interesting about this this
is our biggest rival in the United
States called Expeditors Expeditors calm
they were the flex board of the 80s and
we you can see our growth we did five
hundred million dollars in revenue last
year and our first revenue ever was in
2014 we did two million dollars in
revenue so we've had just the last four
years we've been crazy at flex port and
we we why is that how are we able to
just like grow so fast it's because
people are already used to buying
Freight if you build a brand new piece
of software and you have to sell
software you've got to convince someone
to that they need something new in their
life and as hard it's hard to get people
to change and want something new that
they've never done before but if you're
a company you already have a budget to
but to ship right you ship Freight every
day
spend trillions of dollars worldwide on
Freight so if you're just a little bit
better you should get the whole market I
think we're a lot better but you should
get the whole market just by being a
little bit better and so by taking that
combination of adding technology to this
infrastructure and expertise problem you
can you can grow super fast and I would
I would look very much my working
framework for how to find good problems
to solve it and not everybody has
experienced firsthand these problems
like where should you go look of course
in your own life look for the problems
and get pissed off about them but but
one good framework is just take that
global GDP pie chart and look at the
segments of it and I would actually just
take the GDP pie chart and divide each
section by the number of hours of
computer programming that have been
applied to it and you have a pretty
decent framework for like where do the
opportunities still remain I think
there's going to be huge opportunities
and parts of the world the Internet
hasn't quite turned upside down yet
because you got to expect that software
and the internet and these technologies
are gonna touch every single aspect of
our lives it's quite interesting to even
look around we're in a pretty tech
enabled place I see a lot of devices
that are tech like connected in some way
electronic but if you actually just like
did a mental calculation of everything
in my field of view right now not
counting all of you people what
what things are connected to the
internet what are the objects that are
connected right now it's not that many
like this carpets not connected that
ceilings not really connected and you
should expect that with the tech in the
future every single thing is going to be
connected all the time and and so that
that's the world that we're heading into
and there's gonna be tons and tons of
opportunities to find problems and when
you when you find an area where people
are already doing something but software
can make it a little bit better you just
create huge opportunities so this is a
this is a something I shared with my
team they didn't make this slide that
just the way I wanted them to I should
make my own slides but the on the left
you have seashells
okay and and the next column over is
limestone so seashells when they are
buried into the bottom of the ocean and
they get pressurized and crushed by the
by the weight of that ocean they become
limestone there's also some
microorganisms in there in calcium
carbonate but it becomes limestone when
that sea bed when that sea bed floor is
submerged by plate tectonics if it's at
the intersection of two plates like we
are here one of them gets abducted and
in the pressure of that it bakes it into
marble and that marble can be built into
something beautiful and so I use this a
lot at my company to talk about how much
pressure we're under you if you go and
start a company you're gonna it's going
to be ridiculously challenging it caused
a lot of anxiety and your gut like it is
not easy to get something going from
nothing and you have to make sure as
your team that if you're working with a
team you can get ripped apart by this
pressure you can get in fights and and
and really rip each other apart so I I
try to bring this to my team and say
look we have to use that pressure we're
it's so hard we have a thousand
employees right now at Flex work and
we're five years old can you imagine
like uh-huh five years ago is me in a
garage and now I have a thousand
employees looking to me for guidance and
I try to use this metaphor and say okay
it's gonna be really hard and we have to
use that to make ourselves stronger as a
team and bring ourselves together so
those are just a few of my remarks we
they asked me to leave
for Q&A so I would love to be available
to you to think about how many people
here get planning to start a company
raise your hand if you want to start a
company when you write when you graduate
few of you and how many what are there
what are some of the reasons why people
would want to start a company who's who
raise their hand right there what was
the reason why you want to start a
company to have independence and build
your own things yeah any others like
what are some good reasons why people
would want to start a company childhood
dreams a dreams of what being the boss
fame and fortune others to solve a
problem yeah that's where I would focus
completely all my energy even if it is
fame and fortune that you seek nothing
wrong with that
fortunes probably better than fame but
and there's nothing wrong with that
money is awesome and I trust me I used
to have no money and now that I have a
little money it's so much better
but there are some things in life where
the more you want it the less likely you
are to get it and and if you focus on
the money nobody nobody wants to give
money to people like that
you know you're like greedy and
self-centered and not not you you're
cool but yeah it's not the best way like
it's not who you give money to people
who solve your problem right and so even
if what you're after is to solve money
to be independent you have to focus on
what's the problem
how do I create value for someone else
is if you're creating value for someone
else you'll get money it's one of the
greats I've always been enthralled by
this paradox because I also want money
less the fame but more the fortune and
I've wanted money but I realized like
the more you focus on the money less
likely you are to get it there are some
things in life that are like that and
those are the really interesting things
love is probably one of those things
like the more you want it like start
being creepy and stuff and nobody's so
your focus instead I'm like whoa what
how could I make someone love me maybe I
should hit the gym or like learn be more
interesting work on my cheeks and so
that would be that would be my biggest
piece of advice for those of you who are
in this entrepreneurial mindset it's
awesome there's no better way to learn
about the world and solve problems than
in solving and starting a company that
you'll entrepreneurship you learn about
every aspect of the human experience in
starting a company it's not the best way
to make money frankly like go try and
get a job at Google you'll make more
money but well on a risk-adjusted basis
but you probably won't learn as much
because if you're an entrepreneur you're
every day having learned something new
you've got to learn about leadership and
persuasion and sales and accounting and
finance and marketing and technology and
all its like the amount of things that
you're gonna learn in entrepreneurship
far outweigh any other field they might
at least in my experience um and so I
would focus on that as like how could I
learn the most that's true for any job
even if you want to start a company you
might not be ready yet because I
couldn't have done this if I didn't know
about how hard it was to import stuff
and I couldn't
deduced that without going out there and
getting a job and doing things and
learning about the world so it's even if
you want to start a company and you're
not yet there that's cool go and focus
on how do you learn the maximum amount
of stuff so that because you never know
where you're gonna find out that and
then let yourself get pissed off when
you learn something that's just like
wrong so that would be my big advice for
y'all my big parting words but I would
love to take some questions from the
audience who has a question yeah I think
in the back recent Packer news interview
with Vinod and he has this concept of
building a zero billion dollar company
over a zero multi-million dollar company
basically give like 15% of your equity
to your first three founders even if you
hired them after I was wondering to hear
your thoughts on weight again so it's
building a zero billion dollar company
so the talent is like that high of a
caliber and you carve out most of your
equity versus a zero million dollar
company basically the engineers you can
find to help you build it hmm is the
idea to give more equity to better found
I'm not sure I understand stay fit the
whole rapid growth that you're
anticipate hiring talent is like in
credits for a question hiring talent is
incredibly hard especially when you're
nobody yeah and getting convincing
people to come on board I I highly
recommend that you not musics as an
excuse that you can't find a co-founder
and that you just get started and do it
yourself it the same is true like if you
need investment money and you can't to
get your business off the ground you
need an investor maybe you should maybe
there's a different business that
doesn't need an investor because there's
a lot of problems in the world and
they're not all and and you can do I did
flex for my third business that's worth
talking about the third one that that
generates profits and what doesn't
generate profit yet but third one that
generates some real revenue didn't use
any VC for the first two I had
co-founders for the first two and flex
board I found it by myself solo founder
in part because it's so much easier like
number one reason that startups fail is
that founders getting a fight so I you
know if I'm gonna fight with myself that
we have a different problem and so I but
then what I did I basically have
co-founders at Plex sport
I got ping off the ground got some
traction even raised some money got some
customers and then i attracted talent a
co-founder level talent but it was four
years out I didn't they didn't get the
title co-founder because it was four
years later just the first four years
was me in a basement and so but but I
was very generous with equity for them
and I think that that you yes you
shouldn't owning a small a big piece of
something that's not worth very much
isn't isn't that valuable so I would
recommend getting started getting some
traction
nobody's gonna join you if you're just
talking and you have a PowerPoint like
they'll join you when you've got
customers and the customers are like
showing it saying that good things about
you then you'll get much better people
for Less equity that if I my co-founder
one of them was a partner at Boston
Consulting Group
my co-founder my CEO oh he was he
partners at Boston Consulting Group make
a lot of money and he walked away from
that because I had a lot of traction we
had a lot of trust amongst each other
but I had gotten somewhere if I tried to
recruit him in the beginning he wasn't
gonna quit that job to join the guy with
the PowerPoint so I don't know if that
answered your question exactly but all
right
yeah so the question was how long did it
take me to get real money from customers
with the company I think we got our
first revenue about six months after I
made it my full-time job and we there
was that period where I was signing up
people but it was just a marketing
website it wasn't a real company yet
once we got licensed by Department of
Homeland Security and actually started a
business before that it was just a
website it didn't really exist it wasn't
even a business entity once we were off
the ground six months to build an MVP of
the product and then what I figured out
was that on Google AdWords I could
acquire a customer for $40 and there
were several thousand dollars in my
estimate at that time this is even the
smallest one so Google AdWords and we
just increased our AdWords spend
exponentially whenever we needed to
raise money
so the question was over the past
hundred years been mostly businesses
doing trade and I you see consumers
starting to participate in trade and
well I think the difference between a
consumer and a business is blurring and
you shouldn't import something as a
consumer you should set up an LLC it'll
cost you like a couple you know not much
money and a boom now you're a business
so what it's on some level that
distinction isn't that real the real
thing is wow it's so easy to start a
company and participate and the
Internet's made it so participatory in
the United States the top one percent of
companies import eight as of 2006 the
last time I've seen this data last night
the last date I have the top one percent
of companies import 80 percent of all
the merchandise instead of 80 20 it's 81
1% imports 80 percent that was in 2006 I
would love to see a refresh on this data
The Economist who did it
it was a paper from 2006 and I got to
Commission him maybe to make it to
update it but my hypothesis is that now
that long tail because of Amazon because
of EJ because of the internet more
broadly it's now possible for anybody to
participate in in trade my own story is
that like when we were importing goods
from China we found all of our suppliers
on the Internet
we're going Holly Baba and other web
sites and identified suppliers and we
found all of our customers on the
Internet you couldn't have done that
business without the internet so yeah
we're the Internet's bringing us closer
together it's so amazing that almost
every human whether what's our mobile
phone number now it's like 4 billion or
5 billion people have mobile phones
which is crazy if you knew the number
you could call almost everybody on
planet earth you could just have a
conversation with them right now and
what is that going to do for us and the
idea that everybody in the world has
Wikipedia and all the knowledge there so
I yeah I think it's there's gonna be
more and more trade we want it we want
to make it possible because those big
companies have the resources and the
knowledge and the know-how of how would
it trade and the the individuals
shouldn't have to think about it they
should focus on making a great product
and finding customers and then like all
the operational stuff in between
make it easy so it was the question was
around much for being a lean startup and
how we went from doing customer
discovery getting out there and talking
to customers and convincing them to try
us out
we um I call it entrepreneurial sales
there's two kinds of sales there's
regular sales and there's
entrepreneurial sales regular sales your
goal is to get to know as fast as you
can because then you can move on to
somebody else who will say yes
entrepreneurial sells you can never get
a no you got to get that yes if yes I
would buy from you if you could do this
and what you would actually do is go on
site we convince people to take a call
take a meeting get on site with them and
add a whiteboard we the the best example
was the world's largest watchmaker we
got their head of supply chain he
responded to a cold email like a spam
email basically spam hi there right and
and so we would get him we got him to
agree to take a meeting and we put it at
a whiteboard and put him at a whiteboard
with a what with a with a with a marker
and said draw for us
your ideal supply chain dashboard what
would you like it to look like and he
drew it like okay I want I want to see
on a map every dot all the icons for all
my products that are in motion and if
it's and if any of them it's gonna be
late it should turn red it's gonna be
more than 24 hours late having read and
I forget what else he asked for um and
we came back a month later and we had
built that that you know and he was like
whoa I've got a ship some freight with
you guys turned me into a computer
program I didn't know I could do that
and they said okay I will ship Freight
with you if you can hit this price and
the price that he asked for was half of
what we were buying Freight for so like
I you know almost there we then took but
we got his commitment that if we could
get that price
then he would ship great so we took that
to the ocean carrier and said hey I'll
bring you the world's largest watchmaker
if you can give me it wasn't a crazy
price it was just way lower than our
prices we were nobodies but the ocean
carrier was happy to have their business
gave us that price and so it's like
going back and forth and we it's a
chicken and a lot of chicken and egg
problems that need to be solved with
creative thinking and getting the yes
from one side and then yes if from one
side and then see if you can solve that
if and recognizing that you should not
try to solve every year people ask for
crazy stuff right and so didn't but
bring that back your art so it's a bit
dangerous for a startup just to hire our
sales person because regular sales
people are used to trying to just turn
through the lead and get to the one
that's gonna say yes and and ignore all
the ones who say no this is what's very
special about salespeople is that they
can handle rejection in a way that would
like be brutal for the rest of us but
it's sales persons like I don't care
they're very happy they're very
self-confident and and and that's a
little bit dangerous what you need is an
entrepreneurial salesperson someone
who's really creative thinking on their
feet and this your job is it boundaries
to be that person most of the time it's
going to be you and be able to get in
front of the customer and really listen
to their needs and understand it and
then be able to bring it back to your
team explain it and say could we solve
this problem or not most of the time
it'll be not yeah a couple more I won't
have time to get to everybody how about
you right there yeah so the question was
whether we how do we measure I think how
do we measure the impact that we can
have in the value that we create for our
customers lots of different ways to
measure it our biggest customer is one
of the world's largest paper makers and
we eliminated 60,000 emails from their
supply chain team in their first year
with us so that's and we did that
because they they sell raw paper
materials to their customers and we were
we actually this is again a very
entrepreneurial salesperson at Flex port
her name is Julie and she convinced the
she hacked our system basically
and on-boarded 75 customer service reps
we're not customer service software but
she realized that if their problem was
companies were their customers were
calling them asking where's our
containers and they were having to email
their supply chain team who would then
email a freight forwarder and then like
it was taking them four days to get a
response to tell the customer where's
their stuff and Juli realized she's not
a vice-president flex four because she
realized if you could onboard all these
customer service reps they could just
answer that question in real time and so
it's like being super creative like whoa
the platform actually does things it
wasn't designed to do it's always a good
sign
when people start abusing your platform
to do different things that's one really
good example another one one of our
customers sold Amazon last year for over
a billion dollars at the time they sold
they were doing hundreds and hundreds of
million in revenue I don't know the
exact figure and with only one one
person in their supply chain team and a
comparable company would have had seven
or eight people we know because we meet
comparable companies with similar
revenue they would have had seven or
eight people there it's not like this
company didn't hire faster they've we
didn't displace these jobs these people
are working in other parts of their
company but they're not doing bs they're
creating value finding customers or
making a product better and so there's a
bit of an AWS analogy there where in the
old days you had to run your
infrastructure you had to run your own
servers DevOps and all this stuff and
now it's like I just don't worry about
that part there's lots and lots of
metrics on transit time is another one
so when Freight flies on our own 747
there we go two days a week from Hong
Kong to LAX and one day week Hong Kong
to Chicago when when it's on our plane
we do it in two point two days
door-to-door and if it goes through
someone else's plane and someone else's
warehouse and all the confusion in that
process it takes five days doesn't seem
like much but let's say you're a giant
phone maker and you your phones are
worth what does this thing what did I
pay for this thing I like $1500 and so
if a 747 hold a couple of hundred
thousand phones so think about three
days worth of 100,000 phones times
$1,000
a lot of money sitting there and it's so
it's real money and if you can speed up
a supply chain you can you sell those
products faster and put cash back on
their balance sheet so it's another way
to measure the impact that you can have
it's just like giving them back money
and people love you when you do that
when you're keeping time for me so I
don't than to part I'm very happy to say
it talk but make sure get cool over here
yes what what sort of legal barriers did
I did we encounter and how did I
overcome them lots we are licensed by
the Department of Homeland Security
Customs and Border Protection
specifically so the first one was
getting that license that took two and a
half years including an FBI background
check which I passed we we've we've got
a license by the Federal Maritime
Commission to sell ocean freight can't
sell ocean freight without a license
we've got were licensed by IATA for
selling air freight a now licensed by
the Chinese Ministry of calm or get the
name of it but licenses all over the
place that are required to do this
business heavily regulated for good
reason because this is on some level
where the front lines against all kinds
of stuff drugs terrorism counterfeit
goods like you you have a an obligation
to report things to the government and
they want to make sure that there's no
bad actors in this in this very
sensitive part of the world economy and
we're not like you know there are other
startups that are I call them test cases
like uber and airbnb and these startups
that there's sort of operating in this
gray area of the law to test case should
you be allowed to sell the backseat of
your car to somebody else and I believe
you should but the law is not on it is
that it's a little ambiguity there in
the law that's not us if like sport are
the law is very clear about what you can
and can't do sometimes hard to
understand but it's not black it's not
gray it's black and white and you have
to learn it
and so we've we have to take compliance
super services probably our biggest risk
as a company and we in our industry the
tech industry doesn't have a great
reputation on compliant
so that's something that we have to
overcome okay I'm gonna do just one more
question how about you right there yeah
I didn't sign up and then nothing ever
happened which is okay you know um we're
in business
so I went to business school I have an
MBA and I remember in a marketing class
in business school the professor was
asking how would you know how do you
know how to price your product and and
and everybody they had all these
complicated matrices and survey
methodologies and you could do different
you know algorithms to test what someone
I was like what if you just listed it
for sale at a different at two different
price points and then see which one
sells more or see which one generates
more revenue or what if you listed a
fake product and see if they would buy
it before it exists and it was literally
laughed out of the room as though it was
a joke like this was like they laughed
at me they said this is the dumbest idea
ever to list a fake product to find out
what price you should sell it at and
then turned out that's what we did and
it and it works so there's you know the
Internet's a beautiful thing because it
there's no cost to creating a page if
you were to do that in a retail store
you couldn't how would you do it you'd
have to have the prototype but Photoshop
is a beautiful beautiful piece of
software okay with that thank you very
much safer
[Applause]